it's a bit like uh if you see if you're
in a marathon a day you come back and
you charge your battery up to about five
percent
so i'm now not a hundred percent when
i'm at five percent battery and i go in
and then i eke out the five percent over
the day and then
you get down to zero at the end and i'm
doing this stand-up comedy gig at the
end of the day
you know you have to kind of raise the
bar so running
plus an hour of comedy it's a tough
thing but we're raising money we're
breaking
our old records and uh the people of uk
and the world are being very generous so
it's great
yeah and you must be feeling you know
now the end's in sight you must be
feeling on a bit of a high you've had um
quite a lot of famous friends drop in on
you via zoom
uh during the whole process so talking
and running you know not easy at the
best of times but
has it been a help or a hindrance to
have those guys tune in
no i asked about a lot of them aren't
actually friends they're just people
who've been asked and i didn't know them
i mean i knew judy dench and she was
wonderful and she came on i didn't
actually know she'd been asked but um
other people asked her and and that was
great
um so it's a help because running on a
treadmill if anyone's tried it if you do
it for you know
half an hour okay that's kind of the
limit but this is six and a half hours a
day so
being able to talk to people even though
i'm out of breath really helps get the
message through and then
people jump on eddies.com make a
donation and they seem to
appreciate the effort that's being made
well it's a huge effort and
what injuries have you got do you have
any bunions or corns to
talk us through what's happened to you
in the course of the month well my
my toe nail on the left hand side has
gone um
you don't want to really see it i do
you do want to see it you want to see it
yeah
okay here we go
i've got to flip this around if you're
having your breakfast i do apologize but
oh
dear that looks sore
so that's how i don't know if you can
see that's that's what's going on there
and the toenail just came off because i
don't know why why one that one usually
it's an
outside one um but uh
yeah you just do what you can use i had
to strap up the leg left leg i've got
tenocylovitis
in my right shin which i've never even
heard of sounds like a bad leader but
that's
my your your tendons and scraping and
getting inflamed i could hear them
scraping as they moved like a hinge
but you know you you straight you strap
yourself up you go on
keep going and uh and again you know
people seem to appreciate okay okay
you're on and on and on and
celebrating a different city in a
different country as we go and it's all
virtual uh from one place and you stay
covered safe and try and get it
get the amount of money raised going up
and up and up we've broken 150 000 now
we're heading 175 000
and there's a double marathon double
marathon on the last day
extra marathon so i'm going to run two
marathon distances on the sunday
oh my goodness and you've not only done
all that running
but as you said you've you've got off
the treadmill and you've literally gone
straight into a stand-up routine
which you've done sitting let's just
have a little listen to one of those
darth vader lord vader i'm lord everyone
lord raider retrieve sabaran von wildham
lord vader
oh that is my favorite and how hard has
it been to get off the treadmill
engage brain and go through a routine
because i actually tuned in
one night and you could just see you
could just see how much of a struggle it
was
at the beginning well i i've been
falling asleep
up to 10 times sometimes it's really
weird you're standing up and you
and the brain does just shut down and
you go out and then you come back up and
you and you're saying weird words which
have nothing to do with comedy or the
what you've just been talking about so
um
that is a little bit alarming but so the
co but the last
show the last day on the 31st that
hopefully should be good i will i will
summon all my energy because i have to
run a marathon then half a marathon
straight after then i go and do the game
and come back and finish the math and
hopefully about by about midnight
uh on the sunday the 31st so that's what
i'm hoping to finish
it is a superhuman effort um can you
sort of imagine what you're going to do
at the end of it is is there something
you're going to do to celebrate some
special meal a drink what do you mean
what are you kind of
fantasizing about the wonderful people
of america have come up with this thing
called brunch some years ago where you
breakfast and lunch goes together so
brunch with a tea at the end
i'm just going to relax and well a lion
and then
and then brunch and breakfast lunch and
tea all sort of rolling together on the
monday monday will be the day off then
tuesday i'm sort of back to
i'll be training on the tuesday that is
a bit a little bit weird but i will be
yeah that is absolutely crazy and just
ever so briefly if someone said to you
right now
let's do this all again next year are
you thinking yeah why not or you know
shoot me now we'll make humanity great
again
it's a slogan of our fund and we're
giving off to different charities and
wonderful charities i don't know where i
got the slogan from it came from
somewhere i can't imagine um but yes i
can't imagine either but
um it's something that i'm gonna have
for life now so i will do more things
i'll keep pushing
and i'll keep reaching out and making
connections around the world
and um you know i was born in yemen i
was born in the colony of eden british
colony of aden
in the country of yemen so the extra
marathon on sunday will be for aid in
yemen where they've got a covid
and the civil war having the same time
such a tough time and then it'll be for
new york and america
uh we'll be celebrating in the afternoon
and evening um so i'll just
i'll just keep going after this into the
future match fit for life
you are running girl um thank you so
much and good luck just
two more days to go it's been an
absolutely fantastic effort thank you
eddie
thank you